[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
I'm gonna try to keep my cool today
man maybe not I don't know [__] should I
be pissed off clay Higgins of Louisiana
and saying there's no such things as gun
violence
clay Higgins of Louisiana
the the what looks like the epitome of
white gun culture
is saying there's no such thing as gun
violence it's only human violence
and that and that guns are not the
number one death for children
in America as as the Nazis keep
gaslighting us
it's gonna get worse and worse and worse
for them the two eight Bros have lost
the plot here
uh in in this attempt to
demonize dehumanize
and strip away the rights of trans
people
D with their absolute obsession
sexual Obsession Obsession it seems to
guns they're white gun culture there is
they are the plot is slipping right
through their hands
now
it appears that there is more to the
story of this shooter than just this
person was transgender
but the two-way Bros are struggling
hard
very hard and I'm talking to you [__]
haters out there that's right if you're
listening and you're getting your
[__] feels up
if your snowflake is kicking in there
because of what I'm saying I'm talking
to you
you [__] Nazi I'm talking to you
if you get mad when I say transgender
or if you get mad when I talk about you
as a two-way bro
get all up in your [__] Fields you
get that snowflake fan inside of you
that's a you problem
it's not my [__] problem
it's not
the majority of people in this country
are appalled
Paul that what we put up with
the safety of our children oh just lock
the side doors they'll shoot the windows
at you dumb [__] they're
high-powered rifles
we'll just give the cops body armor
it it'll Pierce through soft body armor
I don't know if you noticed yesterday
the um and I'm not gonna play it
because I'm not gonna play [__]
transgender killing porn for these
[__] two a Bros these [__] bigot
Nazis out there that's right I'm calling
I'm you get all upset when I call you
Nazis you [__] haters but that's what
you are
so I'm not gonna play the police
officers getting into the school
and using their courage
to make sure to save children no matter
who had the gun
because it's not the person you [__]
dummies it's not the person it's not
mental illness that's running around
with guns
it's not
we
our country our government We the People
are allowing
this to happen
this is our fault
again there's another shooting it
happened another active shooter
apparently right now I think in
Pittsburgh
at a [__] school
this is our problem this is of our doing
you know when we didn't have this
problem it's really it's really weird
really weird we didn't have this problem
from 1992 to 2002. didn't end this
problem
and the reason why we didn't have this
problem is because this country went you
know what common sense safety
when it comes to weapons of Wars
probably a good idea
we've been doing it with automobiles for
[__] decades since the late 70s early
80s
we're like you know what we should do we
should make the manufacturers put in
seat belts hmm we should really make
them crash test these these big huge
hunks of metal
that we're driving down the road maybe
we should do that
maybe we should make them adhere to
safety standards you know what we should
also do you know we should also do make
sure drivers aren't impaired when
they're driving these big huge hunks of
Weaponry down the street oh and these
killing machines that everyone's driving
around maybe what we should do is make
sure people are [__] licensed
uh you know what we some states are like
you know we should do you know we should
every [__] year we should inspect
these big hunks of [__] murder
machines that are rolling down the road
to make sure they're I don't know safe
you know we should also do that's well
yeah I think what we should do is we
should make sure that the people driving
and operating these pieces of Machinery
that are designed to drive
that are a leading cause of death in
this country at the time not anymore
well you should make those people get
insured in case they do get in an
accident and they do damage property or
I don't know kill someone hmm
seems Seems like we are really easy to
do that
most people don't bat an eye you know
what also Most states do
if you get caught not doing that [__]
while you're operating one of those big
hunks of metal
that roll down the road that are one of
the leading cars used to be one of the
leading causes of death and you don't
have license insurance tags
you're not your vehicle isn't inspected
the state regulations
you you lose your [__] license
and if you do it enough they'll [__]
arrest you huh
well God damn
now most people say Tony it's not the
same it's it's really not the same
Automobiles and assault rifles and
handguns and weapons of war they are not
the same
there I'll give it to you two way Bros
here's the difference
an automobile is designed to get from
point A to point B maybe hauling stuff
you know it rather you're going to work
going to school or just transporting I
don't know goods or services there's all
sorts of reasons for an automobile one
of them is not killing human beings
that's not I mean the automobile
manufacturers aren't like I wonder if we
can make this automobile kill as many
human beings as possible in the least
amount of time they're not doing that
you know what the gun manufacturers are
doing you [__] morons
do you know why we do you know why do
you know why liberals
and US average Americans as common sense
people call it weapons of war do you
know why we call it that
do you have any clue why
you're like Aaron internet weapons
awards are completely different go ask
go ask someone who had their [__]
head attached when they were in the
[__] military how they treated
Weaponry of War
gun manufacturers design Weaponry of War
to kill as many human beings as possible
in the least amount of time
whitetail deer aren't heavily armed
wild turkey aren't wearing body armor
you dumb [__]
I grew up in rural [__] country white
redneck a stand you dumb sons of [__]
I remember what guns were like in the
1980s and the 1990s I remember during
the assault weapon ban how people had
their mindset around guns you stupid
[__] what are you gaslighting us for
do you do you really think we believe
that nonsense
that an AR-15 is used for hunting
and it's all right to have guns to kill
politicians that's where they're at now
when I was a kid when I was a kid the
whole the whole argument around guns as
well uh we need them for hunting we need
to you know to control the population of
whitetail deer and wild turkey so that
white-tailed deer don't cause property
damage when they get on the highway and
someone hits them with an automobile
that was the that was the [__] the
argument
even Columbine Columbine happened and
the entire country went whoa what the
[__] is happening what the [__] is
happening
Wayne lapair Wayne lot payer went to
Congress
and sat and testified in support of gun
reform
do you know what the gun manufacturers
found out though real quick change
waiting lot Pierre's mind like that you
know what they found out the more
shootings that happened
the more shootings that happened what
happens is the country goes whoa what
the [__] are you kidding me why why are
we letting people have access to this
kind of weaponry
and the gun manufacturers like hey NRA
do us a solid and get out there and
spread some fear around that they're
going to take away your [__] guns
and that's what the NRA does that's what
the gun lobby does
and these two a Bros get terrified oh my
God
Obama's gonna take your guns Hillary's
gonna take your guns Joe Biden's gonna
take they're not taking your [__]
guns when's the last time you've seen
a [__] gun banned on the market
1992. you dumb [__]
the best they could do is Bump stocks
that's it that's it that's the best they
can do and and you two a Bros out there
that say any infringement on the Second
Amendment is [__] is treason someone
tweeted that at me the other day by the
way using my first amendment to talk
about the Second Amendment is to reason
hey there's 26 other amendments you
[__] idiot
1992 is the last time we did we did
anything substantive
about getting weapons of war off the
streets of America and it worked
do you know when it stopped working when
the ban expired in 2002 it was a 10-year
ban
America's sick of your [__] they're sick
of it they're [__] sick of it even
people who own weaponry and that's the
other thing where they're losing the
plot line here
they're totally losing the blotline
liberals own guns
people in the lgbtq community
they own guns black people own guns
Hispanics own guns
there's more [__] guns than people in
this country
how don't you know that the majority of
people are gonna have some guns and most
gun people are gonna have more than one
and when there's more
semi-automatic weapons on the market now
than there has ever been it is likely it
is likely
that people are going to own and have
access to semi-automatic weaponry
these aren't hard things to understand
they're not most people with [__] two
brain cells to rub together understand
them
and they also if you have two brain
cells to rub together you can read the
Second Amendment and understand what the
[__] it says and also if you have three
brain cells it might take three two
abros it might take three
if you got three brain cells rolling
around in your [__] empty little
skull there
maybe you would understand the history
of the Second Amendment or any of the
Amendments really any of them I mean
there are 27 it would be nice for you
guys to go look the other 26 up
it's like it's like you don't even know
what the word Amendment even [__]
means or when the amendment that you
love so much that you're jerking off to
right now
when it was established do you have any
clue what year they did the Bill of
Rights
when they did the Bill of Rights how the
Bill of Rights came about do you know
the history of it no you don't
you don't
and the reason why you don't and you
won't is because it it completely just
it completely disables your entire
[__] individual argument of the
Second Amendment
completely disables it as if as if the
right to own any gun anywhere anytime
carry in it anywhere without any
regulation at all is somehow the the
founders that you love the slave owning
Founders that you love was their intent
you you completely ignore I mean I'm not
even gonna say well regulated we'll
leave that out you completely ignore the
word militia in it
completely ignore it
not you don't even know what it means in
the context of the Second Amendment when
they wrote it
or or the other good one the other good
one is when you you say tyrannical
government and you don't even know what
governments
your your [__] God's on the highest
hill the slave owning founding fathers
which governments and which tyrannical
governments they were [__] talking
about
people are [__] brain dead
and I said yesterday you know I'm not
getting as pissed today because I'm not
actually
focused in on the [__] little
children that were murdered yesterday
and probably the little children that
will be murdered in a school somewhere
today
because of your stupid [__] arguments
and your stupid white gun culture
because that's what it is folks I don't
give a [__] what you say I don't care
how you frame it I don't give a [__]
I've seen it I lived in it and I'm
watching it now it's white gun culture
that's what it is I don't give a [__]
what you want to say
you we'll we'll go at it all day long
I know what it is I know what the
problem is it's the [__] guns but
more than anything it's the goddamn
religion of guns in White America
when I grew up in White America I grew
up on a farm
it was several miles outside of town
our closest neighbor was a quarter mile
away
it was hard to see their house without a
pair of binoculars
okay
there was no one around
we had guns in my house when I was a kid
there were shotguns
there was deer rifles there was 22s we
didn't have any pistols we didn't have
any handguns just rifles
some of them family heirlooms some of
them were my fathers my dad's hunting
guns
never ever
was there ever discussion in my
household when I was a kid
where they were like hey go stand in
front of the tree and hold your shotgun
never
it's I want to think
the only time we appeared in a picture
with a gun is when we shot a um a deer
or a turkey which the funny part about
that is I I can't get over this you
actually have to go buy a tag in the
state of Missouri you got to go buy a
license
to [__] hunt
and to buy a tag so you can go shoot
that deer you can't just randomly go out
and start shooting deer and turkey with
a gun not not a thing or a bow and arrow
for that matter Compound Bow crossbow
nope can't do it can't just go start
shooting [__] animals you gotta have
a license you gotta have a tag to even
use your gun on an animal
you stupid [__]
that's the only time we appeared
as children
when there was the youth hunt
and they were trying to teach us gun
safety and how to hunt deer not not
humans deer with a deer rifle
a lot of people are going to say well
Tony you get upset of a [__] those deer
Rivals are those Jack same thing as
these AR-15s
really so you have an AR-15 not not to
defend yourself against the tyrannical
government
not to defend your home and protect your
your your family it's for deer hunting
is that what you're saying
is that is that the argument is that the
national is that what the NRA is saying
is that what the gun lobby
is saying
because maybe maybe you're just out of
the [__] Loop
why do you think America is so pissed
off why do you think America is
clamoring to make sure that people don't
have access to weapons that can murder
dozens of children
in a matter of seconds
if you two a bruise
do not and I'm talking to you two ladies
who are militant about it I don't give a
[__] when I say Bros I'm not talking
about a certain gender here
I'm talking about your [__] attitude
and your [__] bone-headedry
towards this issue
if you do not pluck your head out of
your ass
and realize
where where this country is gonna go in
the next two and three decades with
these weapons you are going to lose all
of your guns
all of them the ones that my dad had
when I was kidding they they won't exist
they'll come take your [__]
I am almost for sure
that these children
that are being terrorized Now by your
right to own Weaponry Whenever Wherever
however
they're being terrorized by these ideas
that you have that the gun lobby the NRA
and these Republican scumbags
keep in place
I almost bet
that when these children inherit this
country
you know as the Millennials are
inheriting the country now as gen Z will
be inherenting the country in the next
10 or 15 years the generation below them
to inherit it after that
and the next two or three decades you're
It's Gonna Be A Hard Sell
to these folks that are going to be
adults who went
terrified through school
that there was going to be a [__]
shooter not just at the one school
they're at but maybe at every single one
of them I mean you know you get you get
in a [__] mass shooting in a high
school you go to college by God it
happens there too
this is America baby
we got mass shootings
like we got [__]
apple pie and fireworks
if you think when their children now
just stay with me I'm not just talking
about them
when they start to send their children
to school okay because you're not
getting rid of schools I I understand
that's your goal is to get rid of public
schools I I get it I understand what
you're trying to do I see you I see you
[__] Nazis
but if you think when that generation's
children get old enough to get into
school
that they're not that they're gonna say
you know what there's something we can
do about this
there's something we can do about that
we've done it before it was a long time
ago
a long time ago
but there was a period of time in this
country where these weapons were banned
I think we could do that again
and I think they'll take it a step
further so my advice
instead of running around making stupid
[__] arguments that the majority of
Americans not only are [__]
see-through that you're a [__] liar
clay Higgins there's no such thing as
gun violence there's only human violence
you are you people are some dumb
[__] man we see it we see it we
see every single one of these mass
shootings in schools churches grocery
stores no matter the no matter the
motive no matter the person no matter
who it is what genitalia they have what
skin color they are who they hate who
they don't hate whether it's a Revenge
situation
rather they have mental illness or don't
have mental illness we see we see the
common component
of what is killing people
it's the [__] gun
it's the [__] gun it's really simple
it's not it's not it's not hard
to understand if you just want to know
the [__] truth it's really [__]
easy and most Americans I'm talking
almost in the 70 percent see this and
I'm talking in the 90 percent want
something to be done to where children
are safe in schools
now we can argue the points of how we do
that but it's obvious that lock side
doors aren't the answer fences aren't
the answer security guards aren't the
[__] answer
more guns is definitely not the answer
Jesus Christ some of these shooters have
two or three guns
two or three think about this if the
logic is that more guns more safety
well if a mass shooter has four or five
guns then they're more safe right
I mean more guns more safety right
foreign people see through your stupid
[__] arguments two-way Bros you
haters here
they [__] see it
they're not dumb
even people who aren't paying attention
to this issue on The Daily
which there are some out there that keep
track of this every [__] day for us
Shannon Watts is one of them
but if you think you can keep lying and
keep saying stupid [__]
like there's no such thing as gun
violence there's only human violence I
mean you know
it's a funny joke clay Higgins I think
it's a funny joke that you think you can
just paper over three children and three
teachers being murdered yesterday in
Nashville and now a shooting I think in
Pittsburgh is where it's at [__] who
knows there's probably going to be
another one by the end of the day this
is how it happens it comes in waves
people see someone get famous for using
a weapon of War at a school they want to
be famous so they go through the same
stupid [__] thing
there's copycats on this [__] all over
all the time
it's one reason why we have to shut this
[__] down
and governor governor drag queen
over there in Tennessee governor van
drag he wants they want a band drag
Tennessee and they did they band dragged
oh boy it's a danger to children I mean
those drag shows are really killing a
lot of children I'm serious I mean
ripping their bodies apart that you you
can't imagine what a drag show will do
to a kid I'm serious rip their [__]
head off they'll be bleeding limbs
falling all over the place
I'm telling you the parents wouldn't
even be able to identify
agile after it goes to a drag show I'm
dead serious they'll be so bloody and
their flesh will be ripped off their
skin so much from a drag show that the
parents would have to use the tennis
shoes to identify the children
the clothes that they were because their
body is so mutilated
if you want to talk about mutilation you
[__] right Wingers you can't imagine
you can't imagine what a drag show will
do to a kid holy [__] oh my God it's
it's gruesome
you can't even hardly look at the
pictures it's so goddamn horrific
what a drag show will do and uh don't
stop there
if you think drag shows are horrible and
they'll rip a child to shreds you should
see what the [__] books do to children
oh my God the danger that books pose to
children in this country
oh my God I can't even tell you how many
times that we can't we can't even show
we can't even show pictures of children
after they've been assaulted by a book
can't even show it
that's how gruesome it is
do you know how [__] stupid you sound
two way Bros do you know how [__]
dumb you sound you [__] fascist
because I see you we see you
[__]
you people out there jerking off to your
guns your weapons of war murdering
children and that's all that matters and
we can't do anything about it
it is what it is what it is
we see what you're doing
we got our eyes on you
and I'm telling you this pro-democracy
coalition
it's coming for you
it's coming and we are going to use our
power to engage in our democracy and we
are going to use our democracy
over the next 10 20 30 years
and we are going to give Liberty to all
people equity and quality to everyone
that's right we woke [__] we
woke we're gonna woke you up [__]
there's one thing we're going to do
though
we're going to stop this nonsense
where anyone can get a weapon of war and
go murder [__] children in a goddamn
School
and if we aren't for that if this
pro-democracy Coalition can't [__] do
that
can't fight for children not to be
killed
then we've lost the battle we've lost
the battle on [__] women's rights
we've lost the battle
on trans rights on lgbtq rights on human
rights we've lost it
they want us to shut the [__] up
about assault weapons they want us to
shut the [__] up about the Second
Amendment they want us to shut the [__]
up about reg having Common Sense gun
safety and regulating firearms and the
people who [__] handle them in this
country
now I'm not gonna shut the [__] up about
it
our children's lives are at risk
and I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__]
who's got the gun
I want we need as a country
need to put an end to anybody and
everybody
legally illegally concealed not
concealed it doesn't matter we have to
stop these [__] weapons from pouring
out on our streets
and getting into the Weeds on each
individual well this person here and
this person there and that person there
this trans person oh there's a white
dude and this guy this cheater here that
shooter there it's the [__] guns
it's the guns
it's
the [__] guns everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
looks like the active shooter situations
and some of these uh schools are all
hoaxes it's just phone calls
just phone calls
do you know what do you know do you know
why they're terrified of a hoax phone
call
hey hey haters hey 2A Bros
hey fascist hey you Nazis in the chat
yeah I'm talking to you if that pisses
you off if it makes you mad that I'd say
the word Nazi I'm I'm talking to you
if it makes you mad
that I say that
I'm talking to you
the reason why
people are terrified
of these hoax
of a phone call to a school
to just say hey there's somebody with a
gun
on the campus
it's it's the gun
it's it's the it's the gun
they're not like hey there's a trans
person on the campus
and they may have done
hey there's a white dude on campus
and they may they may have again
it's the [__] gun
again yesterday I got really pissed off
I don't apologize for it [__] that [__]
I'm not gonna apologize for it for being
pissed off I know all of you out there
who listen every single day well the
majority of you
slide some of the heat launchers here
and I know you're just as pissed off or
more pissed off than I am and I know
that sometimes you come here to this
show for cathartic release I get it
I understand it
I understand why you come here
uh for the cathartic release
because I say the things that maybe you
can't or or shouldn't
or shouldn't probably
oh I'm not gonna [__] apologize
someone says no [__] apologies yeah
I'm not [__] apologizing for [__]
ain't gonna get [__] and I'm talking
all the two late Bros out there ain't
gonna get [__]
hey why is Tony so fat
do you know how fat works you know how
fat works like you know how guns work
dog dog why 42
let's see you put one of your real
pictures there up on your avatar do you
know how fat works here here's how it
works I like to eat
that that's that's why I'm I'm fat
because I like that I like that's how
fat Works normally
that's how it works
I'm working on it I'm working on it I
don't know if you [__] noticed
but I'm working on it I'm trying to get
there
I I've been fat before I've been fatter
than I am now dog y42 why am I so fat
you don't know how [__] fat works you
know what we should do
now we should do is shoot the [__] here
real quick who wants to do shoot the
[__] yeah we should do that [__] it
let's just call it shoot the [__]
Wednesday I don't know feels like a good
day to do it I like today is going to be
a good day
I like today today is going to be a good
day we're not gonna let these
[__] ruin our spirit for our
democracy
it's not gonna happen
we are going to engage in our democracy
we are going to use our democracy to
save it and that one of those things
is
to shoot the [__] so let's shoot the
[__]
let's see if you guys got questions you
guys I want to shoot the [__] is you
should know by now if you've got
questions
um stick them in the chat there I'll
answer the questions some of the
questions that I get I can't answer all
we don't have that much time if you guys
uh want
um you guys want to do an ask me
anything on patreon here soon
um we can do that
I'm probably gonna be pretty inebriated
the next two days you know on Wednesday
and Thursday are for me but maybe maybe
tomorrow or Friday maybe Friday after
the show we'll do a ask me anything
if you're on patreon you go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels you can
join there
and you can we can do the ask me
anything on Friday and I will answer
literally any question you have ask the
folks in the chat that have been do they
ask me anything I won't answer anything
it doesn't matter what it is so even you
haters if you want to come ask a stupid
question yeah I'll give you an answer
you damn right whatever whatever
question you want to know uh so get your
get your questions in the chat here and
I'll try to uh answer those things
dog wife
I don't everyone's asking if she's
married to a dog I I don't know I have
no idea
I I don't know I don't know I I you know
really honestly when someone identifies
either their gender or their sexual
orientation like in their their handle
it doesn't bother me whatever you want
to do if you want if you want honestly
if you think you want to be married to a
dog and you want to be a dog what
Finance that's cool
that's cool that's cool oh here see then
they got they got more jokes oh yeah
who's who cut his hair probably a Nazi
yeah you think what do you think about
the new haircut huh I think everybody
likes the haircut dog wife I think
everyone likes it I don't know
I I like that I like the the mid fade
close look with the comb over on top you
should see what my hair used to look
like it was way worse than this this is
my best haircut I got okay
so you know you call it whatever you
want Call It Whatever you want see see
here's here's the difference dog wife
you're mad you're mad that I say Nazi
you're upset you get butter you're like
oh man oh man that gets in my feels I'm
gonna type in some [__] to Tony about
his haircut
and about how fat he is I can't make a
substantive or argument about what he's
saying so I'll call him fat say his
haircut sucks
but when you say when you say my haircut
looks like a Nazi did it I pulled up on
screen I don't care I don't give a [__]
ah you're funny uh you you should stick
around here dog wife you should stick
around oh man with the fat jokes and
stuff oh boy you're gonna kill in the
chat
okay let's get to some questions here
um
mullets uh Amanda asked if mullets look
good well you said button mullets look
good question mark I know that's a
question for me but it's a question
right
um so
um
so the the uh the mullets
looking good I I mean you know a mullet
can look good I'm not saying it can't
you know there's been times to have
bullets and not times to have mullets to
be quite honest
every once in a while you know the style
comes back around again more do you know
uh have you seen Theo Von theobon's got
a mullet I kind of like his mullet
I don't agree with everything Theo says
but I I kind of like his his bullet
I kind of like that I don't know it
depends on how you cut it really you
know what I mean I mean a mullet can
look decent
it's um decent as a mullet can look okay
uh let's go to another question
um someone said question did you make it
on the Twitter space yesterday at trains
against troll I did not I wouldn't
listen for a little while
the one reason why I didn't chime into
that one is because
um when I was listening they were
talking
um about transgender people and
transgender rights and the ins and outs
of that and and I honestly
I I don't I don't believe as a cisgender
white male
if then I can that I can contribute to
the experience of a transgender person
that's why I don't want people
legislating what they can and can't do
right or who they can and can't be
or what what what
kind of idea that they have of what
gender is and what it isn't I I am of
the belief
that we shouldn't be legislating those
any folks out of existence to be quite
Frank
any of them I I actually believe that
the Nazis that went to Wadsworth Ohio to
protest the drag show I actually believe
they have the right to do that
I mean they look [__] dumb they look
bigoted it just shows how aligned with
Nazis the Republicans truly are and this
anti-drag anti-trans anti-lgbtq it is
clear as day that the fascists are using
it to push their Nazi agenda inside the
Republican party I mean that's obvious
but I actually think that's the good
part about them the Nazis going to
Wadsworth and expressing their first
amendment opinion right like I don't
want us to ban Nazis from going and
protesting I think that's wrong
I think that's wrong now they were all
armed and it got heated at moments so
you know I'm not sure if that is
something I mean again
I don't think we should infringe
anyone's right to protest
to protest that that's the key yeah you
don't need a gun to protest
I mean
maybe you're you do you tough gay you
tough guy Nazi but I mean I I I want if
if we if we get to a situation where the
Nazis can't protest peacefully protest
you know within the bounds of Reason
meaning they need to they need to have a
a certain plan for that Community for
for the the law enforcement there uh it
really is disappointing when law
enforcement turns their their eyes
towards the drag show and not towards
the real threat the Nazis but you know
those things can be worked out in
society and it takes a long time to to
build these ideas and to build this
narrative and to show the country who
truly is the enemy of democracy and why
democracy isn't the enemy why democracy
with Liberty rights and freedom will
Deliver Us
the equity inequality most the most of
us desire I believe that's my belief
but if we if we in French
on the ability
for Nazis to have their opinion about
transgender people
then we're infringing those transgender
people's thoughts and beliefs as well
so the reason why I didn't go into the
space is because I felt like the
conversation that was being had in the
space at that moment that my experience
and that that what what my life is and
how I
see the world through my world view of
Liberty I I didn't I didn't think that I
could contribute to that conversation I
didn't think that I would add any value
and because I couldn't add value I
didn't see it appropriate that I would
go up on stage and take time away from
anyone else in the space now there were
some wild ideas about transgenderism in
that space
and and it seemed like in that space
people were starting to agree that that
the only the only concern is with
children
which is one of the problems I believe
with the transgender debate but that's
not for me
I just don't want
Republicans or democrat any politician
legislating anyone's right out of
existence
um we got Gabe Sanchez here going to
join us for uh
for uh shoot the [__] here maybe if you
got a question for Gabe Sanchez how's
how's it going this morning Gabe
well you need to unmute I mean first of
all
that would help yeah nope still not oh
you gotta leave
no ow
okay well let me find another question
why uh okay great Gabe Sanchez finally
gets the get the sound machine good I'm
I'm working on a I'm I'm I I finished
filming and I'm just putting the assets
into the what was that
um I made a little bit of a pivot
yesterday but it's on uh Josh Hawley and
his hypocrisy
whoa whoa wait you mean Josh Ollie is a
hypocrite now you know yeah these things
I I I find that hard to believe you know
you're gonna have to bring the receipts
my friend well I did I did I did bring
the receipts here's here's another good
question maybe you can answer this if
it's nacho cheese whose cheese is it
it's not mine I don't know I have no
idea I don't know I mean like it's a
it's an age-old question from the
beginning of time I think it might have
come before
what came first the chicken or the egg
you know like that's a question that is
been pondering our minds you know or
that we've pondered for many many years
and I think the nacho cheese one
is another one as well and I mean this
is the one we should work on though
oh yes I think that we should we should
definitely fundraise you know do a
little r d on this right
um but I can tell you firsthand
it's not my cheese and it's not yours I
I know it's it's not nacho cheese
and it's not mine
cheese then who's
cheese is it this is not a good question
okay let's let's move on to another
question here we got I'm telling you
what
um
we got this dog wine 42 in the chat and
she called me she called me fat I I'm
guessing what yeah she she didn't like I
said the word Nazi
looks like a Nazi did it what do you
think so then wouldn't this person like
it then if they're offended by you
calling someone a Nazi that means do you
think my haircut looks like a Nazi did
it I mean I I don't know the guy that
well yet yeah she's kind of a newborn is
there is there a is there a certain
symbol uh put into it huh no I don't I
don't have a design he I would like to
maybe I'll maybe that's what I'll do
next time yeah why not yeah pew pew
right something like that uh so that's
that's unfortunate dog wife uh yeah some
people are saying it's kind of weird
that that'd be your handle but I mean
hey you know what again I just said I
don't know I didn't I don't normally you
know get concerned about people's handle
especially when it talks about their
gender or who they love or you know you
do it you do you man you should not be
able to control someone else's choice in
life whether who they want to love or
who they want to marry or who they want
to spend their life with dude life is is
[__] complicated enough we've got so
so much [__] these shootings we've got
other Republicans who are unwilling to
help us with the basic human Necessities
I think the fact that if we're going to
say uh this group of people can't live
their life how they want I think that's
unnecessary if you want to be married to
a dog I'm actually not you know what a
lot of people don't agree with me on
this because we've talked about this
polygamy as long as it's consensual I
think you should be with as many people
as you want if those people it's all
consensual why the [__] not I mean why
the [__] I think it's ridiculous that we
that we tell people you can't do that
why it's an idea I got it it's not done
doesn't [__] with your [__] right
but I do in my home and who I love you
know obviously keeping it legal right as
long as I don't know about this dog why
43 person yeah right I mean you start I
mean I don't know how a dog can sense
really right yeah I don't know idea I
don't know I mean I mean spread peanut
butter somewhere they might consent but
I mean it depends I don't want to think
about it I don't even want to think
about that oh yesterday we're talking
about pudding fingers we've been talking
about putting fingers for a week but
you're scared to talk about what dog
peanut butter again you know yeah people
live their life how they want to live it
and whether or not what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying right now I know
I get it I get it if you if you want
consent from a dog I'm sure there are
plenty of ways to get excited consent
from a dog I'm just saying are we to
assume that dog wife 42 is one of those
people I I don't know I I really I don't
give a [__] I don't even know what is
the dog wife he's a dog wife like oh
this dog like when people are like oh
that's my kid and it's a dog and people
are like oh that's my wife it's a dog or
are they calling
themselves
a dog wife I'm trying that's what I'm
trying to understand here I see the
photos of dog but I don't know if
they're calling themselves a dog wife if
that's some like term for something I
don't know right or or the fact that
they're like oh that's just my wife it's
a dog and it's like playful kind of
thing which is weird when this person's
getting offended by Nazi but whatever
well you know I it happens when I say
the word Nazi and then they get you know
they get it yeah
she said my my new Barber was a Nazi
which and I I mean I've known that well
but I don't yeah I don't get I don't get
nasty but I streaming to be quite honest
um I just I just don't know why I don't
know here look we'll just say this if
you're getting triggered by the phrase
Nazi right right or being labeled or
someone being labeled a Nazi right and
you get very triggered and upset about
it
I don't know maybe that says more about
the you in terms of the person
responding and getting upset right
Nazis are bad I think we should all
agree on that concept here
um that's like an absolute truth that I
think everyone in this audience maybe
not dog wife maybe not other people like
Don Coben or that Dustin guy or others
Dustin but I think it's safe to say like
if there's an absolute truth in this
world is that Nazis are bad right and we
should not accept them in our society we
probably shouldn't be on the same side
as them either no I'm pretty sure we
even fought a World War it was a it was
a war with the world right and it was
the second against these yeah it's the
second one uh did the person ask for its
Paul in marriage I don't know I have no
idea you know again
if you wanna if you wanna you know have
some kind of
um other relationship than pet pet owner
with your dog again I'm sure consent
isn't hard with a dog a jar of peanut
butter will do it I'm just saying they
get really excited peanut butter they
love peanut butter especially like get
the Jif current yeah it's like really
sweet oh yeah they [__] love that
[__] I I don't have I don't have
experience I don't have experience
smooth creamy or crunchy
well like are you like if you're making
a PB j sandwich are you a crunchy peanut
butter oh no no no I I I'm creamy creamy
okay well I'll tell you I like the
little you know a little crunch in the
sandwich you know a little texture
you're I'm not saying they're not the
creamy's not good I'm just saying I like
both but sometimes it's good you like
you like the nuts you know look call me
nuts why you like nuts okay I'm crazy
but I'm definitely nuts okay you're nuts
for nuts well see I found this new thing
um at Sam's Club and you can get it at
almost any grocery store it's powdered
peanut butter like and oh the pb2 or
whatever yeah yeah me too there's PB fit
I believe the one I bought it seems goes
PB fits so it's it's got all the protein
and everything in it that you want it
just doesn't have all the sugar because
see that's the one that's it they ask
why I'm bad earlier that I like or said
I'm fat and I said do you not know how
fat works like sugar sugar is my
Ultimate Enemy right with my weight
because I've struggled with my weight my
whole darn life right it's a [__]
because I'm fat can love food and I love
sugar but this is it's good yeah and
[__] yeah I mean you get addicted to it
but um that this pb2 it's just a powder
and you put water in it you stir it
around and it's [__] peanut butter
yeah I use it I I use it for for protein
shakes I just throw like you throw it in
there with chocolate right it's like a
smoothie right and then you got a
chocolate peanut butter smoothie right
yeah yeah and it's protein shake so but
it but you can make peanut butter with
it but it's not as smooth as like a chip
but it's not as crunchy as with crunchy
peanut butter so it's kind of it's kind
of like just just a little more then and
I'll I'll put it on like a bagel or
something right yeah all right
according to Theron he says pb2 on a
Tillamook Mudslide ice cream is Bomb oh
really now oh well I think I gotta try
that Darren you bastard see I'm trying
not to be fat [__] he's like
look I'm good with the pb2 but not so
good with the Tillamook so we cancel
each other out yeah well here's another
question uh aside from food let's get
off food because your [__] are
making me hungry um what's your
preferred form of government or an
economy what do you mean preferred like
I get to choose is that what you're
saying are I think that we we have one
but see here's here's the problem with
this question I don't know what this
person you know what their direction is
here I think yeah okay right I have no
idea I don't know if it's hey you should
be a left Winger or you should be a
right winger see the problem is is that
when you're when your first thought is
that we should redo
our government we should renew our
democracy we should redo our form of
government and economy what you're doing
is making way for the type of change
that you may not want right because when
you when you ultimately uh overthrow a
government
I don't know if you went back and look
at histories of governments being
overthrown or coups that happen of the
economy or the government but normally
when it happens right the people don't
get to choose the new one right like
that's not what they get to choose but
in the system that we have right now the
one that we're operating in the
two-party Republic the Democratic
constitutional two-party Republic that
we have we have the ability
we don't have the knowledge
or sometimes the will to do this but we
have the ability to make it very close
to what the majority of people in this
country want it's going to take a lot of
time and a lot of work because democracy
as far as a form of government democracy
is one of the hardest that's why I
always say this this idea and this like
a narrative that liberalism is weak is
really [__] dumb go work Look up the
word uh liberal go look up the word
liberalism and then tell me that that's
not going to be [__] difficult when
you have all these ideas all these all
these uh World Views
and you're trying to put them in a place
where the majority of people can have
what they want or who they want from the
government or the economy as you put it
so when you start asking what's my
preferred government or economy my
preference isn't for a certain
government or economy necessarily I just
don't want to topple the one we have to
give opportunity for a fascist
government to take hold right yeah so I
my the most important thing to me right
now in this moment in time in history in
this country in our
Democratic constitutional two-party
Republic
I want the ability for it to survive and
fascism not to overthrow it so again
when you start talking about and this is
this is why I speak out against tyt and
I I speak out against David packman not
only because they're [__] boring in
their media and their narratives are
[__] but when they start saying [__]
like oh we've already lost or no reason
to vote Republicans are going to win
there's going to be a red wave you know
oh where we can't even the Democrats are
going to take away your bodily autonomy
even the Democrats aren't fighting for
Health Care infrastructure they're just
not they're just not for the people when
you start saying that [__] you start
saying that [__] you start talking about
a different form of government right and
you start promoting the ability and make
way for a different government to take
hold and what I don't want I think I've
been clear about it I don't want a
fascist government to take over and do a
coup here of our constitutional republic
that's what they want I'm going to show
you some [__] Clips today they're
going to blow your mind have you seen
this [__] clay Higgins Clinton
um no I don't think oh my god oh it's
[__] you talk about white gun culture
holy [__] because because you you um
gave your your you you're not unique but
your your experience well okay you know
what the [__] I mean my parents say that
I'm unique yeah well you are one of a
kind trust me okay so here's here's what
I mean by this your experience is unique
but I'm not saying it's out of the realm
of there's a lot of people who have your
experience right yeah yeah where you you
have two sets of of Heritage right I'm
I'm just a crusty old cracker white dude
from rule white supremacy institutional
rule America that's what I am there's a
lot of meat there's a lot of me I mean
they're everywhere and that experience
is everywhere but you kind of experience
both ends of that Spectrum yeah you
actually you've talked about on the show
where you like went hunting right yeah
like you you've you've experienced white
gun culture yeah I mean like my my you
know I've got family who live in you
know used to live in Wisconsin and live
in in Minnesota and like this is your
mom's family yeah my mom's family and so
going up there during the holidays like
ever since I was a kid was something
that we would go out hunting you know
you get up at three four in the morning
whatever go to the stoop wait a lot of
waiting a lot of waiting there'd be
crawling through different uh
like weeded area you guys didn't tie up
the deer or tie up the game like the
Trump the Trump Brothers do and no you
know what we also didn't hire someone to
go out and round them up shoot or like
injure the animal right then the deer so
you know we had to do the hunting yeah
yeah I mean I also you know my my uh my
grandparents also lived in like the back
woods and we'd put out like salt blocks
and then I'd hang out with the deer in
the backyard or like the squirrels that
would come eat the corn on this like a
little pinwheel thing that they had but
yeah like I've gone I've lived in you
know I've lived in both uh urban and
rural areas in the sense of like I had
family in both and so like
I live both those lives right I've been
experienced both those lives
um and so I know
you know I know what it's like uh
obviously it's changed a lot in terms of
like accessibility to guns and also the
damage that we have created from those
guns during that time but yeah it's
something that you know I've grown up in
gun culture I don't own a gun I don't
care to own a gun but I'm also not
trying to take away someone else's
[__] second amendment I just want
people to be safer and smarter with the
gun so that less people die it's a crazy
concept so reasonably radical concept
hey can we have less people die that
would be great guys right and then
they're like oh God damn you never come
with my guns I'm not trying to I gotta
I'm not trying to I got a couple
comments here regarding our race
[Laughter]
one is Tony a liberal redneck like me is
Extreme minority I actually don't
believe that Mo I actually most rednecks
are liberal they just don't know it
right they just they just don't know it
they're like yeah
abortion in in uh I'm a white dude
that's being oppressed because they
believe the propaganda right they
believe the propaganda they don't know
that they're liberal but most the time
they are here I just want to point
something out yeah to Edwin I know
you're not saying it's a it's a put down
but I am not a rich kid I was not born a
rich kid I was uh uh I lived in the blue
collar area of my town so I'm not uh
I'm not a rich kid whatsoever and I I
unfortunately
I wish I wish I was rich I wish I was
getting those George Soros checks every
day yeah to find some crazy Network that
we have but unfortunately I'm not a rich
kid I'll tell you I'll tell you what you
are and oh my God this is great this is
funny Paul says I'm half Mexican and
half cracker as well hey here we go oh
man see we don't shy away from the taco
race I I really honestly you know this
is the other reason why yesterday did
you did you listen to any of that space
someone was asking questions about that
space yeah so I was I was actually uh I
didn't go okay here what I'll say is I
went into the space to listen yeah I did
too and uh for the same reason that you
said you're like I didn't feel
comfortable it's
well I I don't think it was my
uncomfortable right now I was I'm always
comfortable to say something yeah yeah
well okay I didn't think I would add I
didn't think I would add anything to the
conversation there is yes
there are certain topics where I think
that people just need to just sit and
listen right not give no I did learn
some [__] though I learned some [__] and
and some good stuff that I thought well
wow I've never looked at it that way
right um but but I also learned some
stuff like whoa that's a wild idea Jesus
Christ I haven't heard that type of
fascism yet and I mean there was uh I
did come so uh Mario invited me later on
and I I came into the space as a speaker
I didn't get to speak because it was
just like crazy what was happening so
basically it was the argument of 2A and
where the guns come from and people not
being willing to accept the fact that
the guns in Mexico who come from the
United States and also those people
being like well you know we should we
should look at
uh at those brave brave officers who
came in and stopped that shooter in
their tracks right
but the argument that a lot of these
people were making and it's all it
always comes down to the [__]
Constitution and they're like this is
what the Second Amendment says
and you got people in there who think
they're constitutional lawyers or
experts or this or that then you've got
actual lawyers who are like look this is
what it says and I'm gonna
I'm going to interpret it this way in my
opinion or I'm going to interpret it or
some people like no this is actually
what the actual text says some of those
people last night were saying things
like
everyone should have access to a gun and
that is the deterrent that we need in
society to which statistically we know
through research and and crime data that
that doesn't happen right this whole
open carry permitless law kind of [__]
actually increases the number of
homicides and gun related deaths
you know so it's it's just one of those
things where like you hear some things
in there if you're like oh man this
tyrannical government a tyrannical
government really you think you're
[__] pistol and your AR-15 is going
to stop a [__] tank if they wanted to
not that they're going to but you think
that they're going to that you're going
to stop them this tyrannical government
because you're well regulated militia
[__] okay
they didn't do
uh the little bit of research that it
takes to understand the con concept of
um which tyrannical government the slave
owning white Foundry fathers were
talking about but you know that's just
here and there we got one more question
from Justin Justin's got a question he
says Gabe is a rich boy I think he
covered that well who cares about his
opinion then hey Dustin hey Dustin
you're the one who worships [__]
billionaires you're the one who thinks
that all people who have money are smart
right you're the one who does that so I
don't know why you come here I don't
know why you come here to if Gabe is a
rich boy if that's the case which he
just told you it wasn't which you can
believe him or not believe him I don't
give a [__]
um but if that's the case why do you
come here every day and listen to what
his opinion is right why why do you do
that oh I know why I know why because
this [__] you just can't look away from
I know I know what yeah see this is this
is the thing and we've had many
conversations about this game Sanchez
this show this show is something that
some people just can't look away from we
are saying things in the political space
in the social space that no one else is
saying how we're saying it they're just
not I again I dare you to go find it I
dare you now there's some good
commentators out there I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to
um you know disparage anyone there's
some really shitty ones and really
boring ones David Pacman being one of
them [__] boring as [__] I'm not
saying he doesn't he he doesn't have an
intellectual ideas he's just [__]
boring and no one wants to hear you talk
about how smart you are they wanna they
want you to tell you what you're
thinking and why it why it makes sense
because that's the thing we don't have
in the media the media wants to talk
over you they want to talk at you they
don't want to talk with you and that's
what we do here on this show is we talk
with you you're part of the conversation
Jesus Christ Dustin how many times have
we brought you up here my friend you're
part of the conversation that's why
you're here my friend that's why you
come hate watch every [__] day so why
do you listen to Gabe's opinion because
he's Rich my guess is you're deluded
that you think he's rich and that you
worship people who have [__] money
that's what I that even if they inherit
it like you're [__] Jesus Donald
Trump inherited yep again I wish I was
are you on musk or Elon Musk he
inherited his money so I wish to tell
you how rich I am all right uh I can't
like I wish I could I wish I had the
money to buy a home right I wish I
didn't have to live in an apartment
I could be a homeowner with a backyard
he would like a place to have a studio
it would be [__] great yeah okay I'll
tell you this much it would be amazing
all right if I had the money
to buy a home and not have to worry
about why living you know what you know
what you should do with other people if
you would just have parents who were
millionaires or really frankly
billionaires yeah that'd be would be
able to do that that would be a thing if
you could just make that happen
just send a text to your parents and say
hey why can't we get this billionaire
thing going on like why you know what I
should do I should have my parents I
should I should tell my parents
um to
to get uh individual personal loans from
the bank that's probably what and then
they should give me that money that's
right and then I should go out and buy a
home yeah and they should probably get
three or four jobs to pay back the loan
that way yeah I mean yeah it's like I
should I should charge them interest
for you know I should just make that
give me all your money guys it's almost
like generational wealth is uh is what
what Dustin you know you would idea his
ideas but he says he loves it he I know
you love the show buddy I know you do I
know you love eight watches Justin is a
great huge right hating fan absolutely
Dustbin comes every day yeah to get up
on the whole [__] thing yeah he
spends two hours of his day and we
appreciate it yeah
who stops by during the day and says
hello and hangs out oh [__] it's uh
Kalyn says many people are saying that
Gabe's dad owns an emerald mine no I
think you're getting confused with
another another person on Twitter see
the the game's dad probably owns HUD
housing that he built in the 1950s and
60s off government loans that he didn't
have to pay back and then he took HUD
funding yeah for the rent for those
people in those homes and on top of that
definitely didn't allow black people in
those buildings that the government
built and the government paid the rent
board definitely that's probably what
Gabe's dad did that's right away and he
probably I bet he took that money and he
went and he [__] it all up in
Manhattan he [__] it all up with golf
courses he lost his entire dad's Fortune
doing really stupid things because he
thinks he's cool that would probably be
what Gabe Gabe's dad did and what gave
his day that's probably yeah I mean
that's that's honestly that is that is
the that's like the biography of my dad
right there now you look up the
Wikipedia are you sure that's not
someone else's biography I was like oh
you know what feels like there could be
something that is someone else's someone
else yeah all right everyone we're gonna
get to the shitless Roundup I got to
show you this video of [__] clay
Higgins it is it is it's [__] mind
bath I can't believe how stupid he
thinks we are everyone here's a shitless
Roundup we're gonna round up the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends as long as they
still exist over there on elon's Twitter
start the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [__] list
[Music]
welcome to the shitless Roundup as long
as elon's Twitter still exist Dustin's
daddy Elon I'm sure that's dude it's
funny because um Dustin's over on
Facebook and and I would say that that
that's kind of cheating on Elon when
you're over on Zuckerberg's you know at
least at least go to you know YouTube
like Google doesn't I know you want but
you know whatever man
well we yeah oh that little attention
that little attention [__] Dustin he
loves when we give him attention
poor little guy poor little guy he
didn't get attention in his real life so
he has to come here and get attention
from us which is totally fine if that's
what you're looking for you know we can
provide you the attention sometimes we
can't always you know right we don't
want to we don't got you to get you to
feel like you have to be dependent or
you're in separation anxiety or maybe
that uh you know you're you're you need
you need this right well he likes the
attention for sure so does clay Higgins
this [__] scumbag he's from Louisiana
look at this guy look at this guy Gabe
Sanchez do you think wow three-piece
suit looks like a douche right I'm gonna
show you let me guess he's gonna say
some real dumb oh about what's going on
is he gonna say something really dumb
he's gonna say something that where I
believe when they were writing this
thing they're like hmm how stupid can we
make people think we think they are I
wonder I wonder if we can really is this
is this uh
is this
a worse take than the representative
from Tennessee yesterday
well I mean they're all [__] dumb but
this one oh man this one is like okay
let's say if you're gonna get a banana
split right okay like some of the
arguments they've been hearing are the
banana right some of them some of the St
and now that now this is a ridiculous
stupid Banana Split right some of it is
the vanilla ice cream you know the white
one some of it's the chocolate ice cream
some of the strawberry ice cream and
then you put the fudge but this
statement from clay Higgins is the
[__] cherry on top of the oh of the
Banana Split okay I'm excited
regarding gun violence
and gun violence being the number one
cause of death of children in America
yeah you'll hear that a lot because it's
correct both
there's no such thing as gun violence
there's only human violence
intellectually on sound to State
otherwise
and the number one cause of death for
children in America
remains abortion no
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my gosh I mean the fact that he's
ignoring statistics like actual data
from the CDC that says hey look uh guns
kill more children than Vehicles do
right crashes the fact that he's
unwilling to look at them but then again
we know that Maga they love their
maganomics and their magnetometry and
their you know all their ways in which
they don't look at science or don't
accept it but this is another situation
where the guy is unable to understand
look okay if it's humans right if the if
if humans are the cause of these death
like this violence is human violence
I would like to see hand-to-hand combat
produce the same amount of deaths that
an AR-15 does in the same amount of time
I want to see how many people
that that a person can kill with just
their hands alone just their hands alone
not a gun
and then we'll look at the numbers and
we'll say hey clay Higgins we'll we'll
understand what the difference is there
right well here's another stupid
argument and this is more like the the
bananas of that stupid argument Banana
Split right this is the NRA they tweeted
this out on the 19th of this month they
had impeccable timing right it says if
you want to ban AR-15s you are an enemy
of the Second Amendment that's it that's
the Tweet now we can go round and round
about this right like we can go around
around about
banning it Second Amendment for an enemy
I mean there are other amendments
there's 26 other ones you have the right
to to want to ban AR-15s it's your First
Amendment right to even say it I want to
ban all guns hey you know what I want to
do I want to get rid of the Second
Amendment I can say it out loud because
I have a first amendment I don't know if
you know that there's one before the
second it's the first one but you know I
know the magnomics don't work in your
head
but this is great I want to show you
someone's response to this NRA tweet and
it kind of goes back to the cherry on
top of the stupid ass banana split and
it's from our friend Hal Sparks Hal
spark says AR-15s are portable abortion
machines
[Laughter]
I mean you know
abortion are the leading cause of death
for children claytons then if we're
getting down with that then AR-15s are
portable abortion machines let's start
let's do that debate I know Hal's trying
to make a a joke here
um and he's trying to throw it in the
NRA's face but you know what
I got to thinking about this tweet this
morning after watching the clay Higgins
the clip of him going like oh the number
one cold so the the other children and
the board
and I got to thinking you know what if
we switched if we switched the
conversation in this country what AR-15s
are and what they aren't and they're a
portable abortion Machines man they're
gonna it's gonna get rough for these two
a Bros and these white Christian
nationalists to start talking about try
to argue and this is the beautiful part
because they're never going to believe
this folks they're not gonna believe it
because it's not it's not it's not true
they're not portable abortion machines
they're they're weapons of war they're
murdering machines is what they are but
when you get them in this argument when
you get them in this conversation that
would be [__] fantastic to listen to
these people like in a space that we go
in why AR-15s are not portable abortion
machines yeah like why they are not that
would be the greatest I would love to
just be a fly on Mike Pence's head when
these [__] 2A Bros are trying to
trying to figure out a way to explain
why AR-15s aren't abortion machines I
think this is brilliant from Hal Sparks
to be yeah no I mean I I completely
agree that if we you know I would
definitely say continue to
pin them in a corner right put them in
this place where you have to make a
decision is it this or is it not this
right do we accept the fact that this
assault weapon right this this
semi-automatic rifle is a death machine
it's an abortion machine right I mean
yeah like
I mean you know if if
if a shooter killed someone who is
pregnant right is that considered an
abortion I you know I right like I don't
know we'd have to ask
clay Higgins dumb ass right like we have
to start having debates with people like
him but a lot of people are going to be
pissed off and they're going to be
appalled by that clip of him saying that
and and because he's politicizing the
murder of children listen folks I keep
telling you this over and over again
they're gonna politicize the issue we
have to politicize the issue too this is
what we have to do that we we can't we
can't out Kumbaya them when they're
politicizing issues and my belief is is
that in the stupid Banana Split analogy
the cherry on top is the most delicious
part right that's the where you start
and that that is like sometimes you save
the Cherry for last some people eat it
first some people shave it for last
somehow I think that this statement is
not gonna be the dumbest one that
they've made it won't be but the thing
is is that we have to keep having these
morons yeah saying these things because
they are losing the plot line right
right it's right I mean out from
underneath them we we've seen over the
last couple days right that Republicans
are saying the quiet part out loud right
they're admitting the fact that they
don't care right you've got the
representative from Tennessee his own
state where where Nashville had the
shooting he goes you know look at the
end of the day I mean this is what he is
paraphrased statement it is what it is
and we can't really do anything to stop
him let me show a clip of two of that
person of that representative saying two
different things and this is why I'm
saying they're losing the plot line let
me show you here he is I forget his name
what's what's this [__] idiot's name
this is the guy that this is the guy
that whispered into Matt Gates's ear
yeah during the vote for house speaker
and that's when Matt Gates went uh oh so
he so he did the whole mobster thing to
him yeah let's let's listen to this
idiot talk about drag shows and shooting
see if you can see why he's an idiot
dadgummit we don't put up with that that
crap in Tennessee and we should we're
not going to fix it criminals are going
to be criminal bad gun
so so banned drag shows because again
drag shows are killing all kinds of
children I mean they're just I mean drag
shows and books I tell you what they're
ripping children apart they're they're I
mean you listen when you when you have
children
um being a victim of drag show violence
or book violence I mean their bodies are
ripped apart the parents have to
identify them by their shoes the shoes
they're wearing that's how that's how
bad it is that's what the Carnage is
with the drag show violence and the book
violence that happens and and he clearly
understands this now I want to play the
full clip
um of this [__] saying it's also it
also seems clear that you know even on
the book Banning side right like you
know Republicans thinking like these
people die by like a thousand paper cuts
kind of thing right they're like oh this
is the real this is the real threat this
is the real thing that is harming our
country these books these paper books
the books that you know it's not gun
violence it's book violence Tony it's
book Vines
that's right are killing the these broke
[__] books are killing people that's
right in the classrooms it's not GunBot
there is no gun violence Gabe Sanchez
it's only book and drag Showbox that is
that is what is here's Berk [__] I think
it work [__] work [__] is that a Berk
[__] burp [__] um so here's berkshire's
full statement here it's only 26 six
seconds of stupidity let's take a listen
free Impressions little kids lost their
lives and I believe three adults I
believe this and um in the shooter of
course across their life too so it's a
horrible horrible situation and we're
not going to fix it criminals are going
to be criminals and my daddy fought in
the second world war fought in the
Pacific about the Japanese and he told
me he said buddy he said if somebody
wants to take you out and doesn't mind
losing their life there's not a whole
heck of a lot you can do about it yeah
that's wrong
uh you can do a whole lot of stuff to
prevent that from happening now can you
go down there's a clip I think in that
thread where they ask him I think it may
be like the third clip down there where
they ask him how he he's got children
he's got daughters yeah here's the and
I'm curious and I want the audience to
see the answer that he gives when asked
how does he keep his own children safe
did you hear this answer I heard this I
honestly heard this answer a couple
times in the space last night when I
went in to go speak this is what they
were saying this is what somebody said
in the space last night okay let's let's
take a listen
plus should be done to protect people
like your little girlfriend being safe
at school well we homeschoolers but you
know that's our decision some people
don't have that option and frankly some
people don't need to do it I mean they
don't have to
um it just suited our needs much better
the luxury right whether you know uh
being a rich kid Dustin
uh or you know indoctrination because
you live in a Christian household I
don't know one or the other but the fact
that these people are look at this and
say
well actually my children don't have to
deal with that because uh we homeschool
them so they don't actually go to a
public school they don't go to a private
school this is something that they most
likely won't have to encounter unless
Tony unless they're in some other public
place like a supermarket or a community
center
or at a game or a concert or a club or
anything else that doesn't involve an
actual School
they they think that homeschooling you
know that's a decision that we made yeah
that's totally within your parental
rights that nobody took away you know
despite the fact that Republicans are
like we got to pass a bill for parental
rights on education no one took away
your parental rights you've always had
them and you've always had the
decision-making power to do what you
want with your child's education but the
luxury that that bird [__] over here has
when it comes to deciding where his
daughter goes to school it's at home did
you did you call him representative bird
[__] yeah bird [__] that's what his name
is
yes
the guy is bird [__] and so what I say
here is this guy has a luxury and also
the four site you know in a way where he
goes look there are these shootings
happening in schools why why would I
want to have my daughter there I should
keep her safe and keep her at the house
where she could be safe but again
as we've learned over the last few years
these shootings aren't just school like
isolated to schools right we know that
they go in other places so I'm sorry I'm
laughing I can't I can't help because
this guy I was gonna play a clip this
guy the other day and we didn't have
time this bird [__] this represented
bird [__] yeah yeah um but I didn't have
time to play it but I just I I tell you
I I've picked out a few clips of this
guy to try to play and I haven't got to
it
um on the show
but bird [__] is very appropriate
because he's dumb he's he's dumb as bird
[__] I mean he's a dumb son of a [__]
he is an ignorant [__] uh speed
him speaking of more ignorant
[__] this is another guy that
shows up in these Twitter spaces I
talked to him the other day or he was
talking about the other day this guy if
people in the end of the day people if
people don't know who Ryan is okay Ryan
uh students from Trump that's I mean
that's really all you need students for
Trump but also people should know that
uh hold on I just want to make sure the
exact the exact
um
I also want you when you're finding your
your thing okay I got it I got it okay
well I want to point out he says nuclear
Maga in all camps but he's following
listen
270 almost 279
000 people and his his account is nine
or ninety thousand my guess is if we
went look this up 70 of that would be
[__] just Bots but then you get the
guy follows
do you know how long it would take
because Twitter and I don't know if they
do it anymore with Elon but Twitter
limits how many people you can follow in
a 24-hour period yeah like do you know
how much time this guy has spent just
[__] Mass following people can you
imagine how much time uh he'll have to
spend to unfollow all of those people
like I don't know if there's a maybe
there's an app that lets you do it like
in bulk but um I I think that's like a
typical because even then that action of
bulk unfollowing would be suspicious on
on the actual back end of Twitter to be
like right uh this might be a bot like
we don't know I mean he is a bot because
he's he's uh and maybe he's got a bot
that I automatically follows like on
list or some [__] yeah yeah you know but
I mean again Twitter only lets you I
thought Twitter only lunch you've all
like um a certain amount of people you
can yeah you definitely you definitely
go uh and Ryan I know you've talked to
me in the space because I'm gonna tag
you in this so if you come back and
watch this episode and you want because
I know you will because these [__]
idiots in this space come back and watch
this show when we talk about him here
they do they [__] love it well
like your little show your little show
My little show [__] you my little show
like like Jim Jim fart or whatever his
name is yeah listen Jim I looked at your
shows that you've had before your four
[__] viewers the ones that you
couldn't get off the [__] ground and
I don't know I know Ryan if you got you
a show or not but you [__] losers you
[__] losers think that I have to go
to this Twitter space and Mario is to
talk to 10 000 people you are dumb sons
of [__] you are you are some stupid
[__] if you think I have to go
to this Twitter space to talk to 10 000
people I go on that Twitter space to
make you guys look like [__] dummies
in front of a bunch of your dumb ass
simps is what my goal is because I feel
like the space because Mario again I I I
Mario has invited us into the space and
that's why I go talk in them
um I'm not I'm not exactly keen on Mario
and some of his views
um but I feel like since he's inviting
us in the space we definitely should
[__] throw fire on the Nazi fire that
they're having in that space and most of
the time when they're talking about
politics and they're talking out their
ass like Jim Ryan dock or Tom Benton or
[__] Seb Gorka you [__] clowns so
Ryan if you're watching this you are a
[__] clown and you're following this
is hilarious man it is hilarious you're
following um but here he says in this
tweet because I want to get to this week
now what you say about Ryan
it says look at this
Gabe look at this a transgender activist
showing off their firearm in a
threatening demeanor oh my God
but the useless FBI won't do anything oh
my God he's so scared of guns he wants
to take the Second Amendment right he
wants to infringe all transgender
people's Second Amendment right they're
really losing the blunt line here
how was this I mean they they really are
because here's the thing like how many
countless videos like who is the [__]
gravy seal guy that's in the backyard
right shooting at every witch I love
those Target in the back I [__] love
those videos by the way oh yeah like if
there's if there's an argument if
there's an argument why people just
shouldn't willy-nilly have guns that
video with that guy is the exact
argument or even the other video where
it's the two guys in the backyard or in
the yard area and they're training and
they keep like getting down when he's
shooting and then getting up and the guy
shoots and almost shoots the guy in the
head knocks his hat off I mean you can
look on Twitter and you can find these
videos but these are the people that say
you're not coming after my Second
Amendment right because God told me I
need to have my
a tyrannical government but these idiots
are the ones who are showing off they
are fetish for their guns they're the
ones who walk into a Subway with an
AR-15 or a bazooka or or random handguns
or whatever it might be because they got
a [__] gloat and show off that they
own guns
look you can own guns that's in the
Constitution that's totally fine but you
overcompensating for whatever's going on
with you and your insecurity
says a lot but when you have these Glory
when you have videos on Twitter or
YouTube or whatever glorifying you [__]
in a pistol and [__] while loading a
shotgun I remember uh an ancient history
it was it was decades ago when there was
a Chinese spy balloon and there was a
U.S senator there was a U.S senator from
Ohio who was newly elected he's a Peter
Theo bought uh uh Nazi and um that that
guy his name is like JD Mandel or
something I think is what his name JP JP
Manda
JP Mandel yeah something like that JD JD
oh that's right JD Vance Houston
he claims he used to be a hillbilly
right he's like I used to be I'm not no
Morse but then when it's convenient he
gets out his gun and he points it up at
the sky now you know not not a
glorifying firearms and a threatening
demeanor or anything oh or posing on a
[__] honest Jesus I love Christmas
fire balloon the same and just so people
remember he posted that photo the same
day that Ohio had the train derailment
so you can understand where their
priorities are right if they oh yeah we
know we know we know it's good we're
just joking that Donald Trump doesn't
know who he is but you look at JD Vance
And he says you know what
I'm gonna take a photo with this big gun
yeah and try to show off my alpha male
status right and that's what a lot of
Republican men do is they try to use
those weapons as like a replacement
for for their small dick that they got
because I believe I believe anyone
anyone who's because there's a what the
[__] is her name out in L.A she's she's
a cop her dad was a cop her brother
they've killed all kinds of people in in
the line and when they're on duty and
she's some kind of [__] gun net and
she posts all kinds of [__] on Instagram
I forget what this [__] oh that's
crazy I honestly don't know who this is
I I forget what her this crazy bitch's
name is but she posts [__] over
Instagram she always like you shooting
at cars and she's holding her guns and
she's glorifying like man if you're up
if you're not upset at her and you're
like yeah rad that's so cool
six thumbs up six hearts you know
whatever I don't know what kind of
emojis you [__] weirdos are putting
on those uh uh Instagram and I'm sure
you go over the post you'll see it but
for for Ryan here to be like oh man
here's a transgender with a weapon and
they're using it in a video on the
internet you know threatening demeanor
but the FBI won't arrest this person
dude
you need to bring the same energy for
other people Ryan you [__] idiots
it's also the same energy that a week
ago Tucker Carlson was using on a show
to say that trans people should not have
guns and right and they're they're
Uprising and then of course this
shooting happens and the shooter is
trans and now the Republican party is
pushing an idea that it's mentally ill
trans people and this and that even
though
it's not the fact like mentally ill
people are not violent right it's three
to five percent of them are and it's
very rare okay and the idea that they're
like oh it's mentally ill people oh
that's trans it's mentally ill trans
people it's just an excuse
for them to attack the trans Community
well I I want to say too what Ryan's
doing here now right-wing coat pointed
this out because I follow right-wing
cope
um and so I pointed and say but they say
conservatives are now trying to attack
trans people they find for the crime of
exercising their Second Amendment right
but here's what I want to say about this
um for Trans people to have second
amendment rights Ryan here would have to
believe that they're humans and that
they actually are afforded those rights
see that's what Ryan's saying that's
what the right Wing's saying that's why
I say the plot line is slipping through
their fingers here is because not only
giving away the game that second
amendment shall not be infringed and
then it's inalienable and it's god-given
um that also that transgender people the
LGBT community are not humans that's
what they're saying that that's that's
where the fashion comes in right that's
that's when they're really showing their
Hitler off okay that's when they're
showing up I want to show you another
example of this well before we go on I
just want to quickly so Ryan for people
who don't know who Ryan is right so he's
the students for Trump founder okay
turns out and you learn this in many of
these spaces when you're like who's that
person then you Google their name you're
like oh wow they're just as shitty of a
person as I thought they were right so
should they say matches the [__] they
believe yeah you're like that's if I had
to put a face to the name and a
backstory to that person it totally adds
up right you don't have to be like a
forensic you know investigator or a
profile to be like nope I'm pretty sure
I got that one on the head right there
so Ryan uh he ratted out his friend to
the feds okay so students for Trump
co-founder John Lambert was sentenced to
13 months for operating a fake Law Firm
Fournier still has not faced prosecution
according to court records the New
Revelations about four years alleged
involvement in the fake law firm again
they ran a fake Law Firm okay so that is
this like a Tom Fenton type Law Firm
kind of thing guessing so I'm guessing
they were offering they made
Law And Justice well according to this
it says that Ryan helped his friend
create a fake Law Firm to build innocent
clients so they're probably giving you
know illegal legal uh advice only to
turn against a one-time partner to help
federal law enforcement because again
all of these guys are snitches if given
the opportunity these alpha males these
guys who have to hold their guns and
second amendment the Constitution will
[__] flip in a second and you'll see
that again and again so the New
Revelations alleged involvement the fake
Law Firm came after sentencing hearing
or a federal judge sends Fournier
students for Trump co-founder John
Lambert to 13 months in prison for
operating a fake law practice now for
whatever reason and probably because he
gave up info and snitched on him you
know kind of like uh the you know
Brandon straka the Jan six writer who
another one spaces another one in this
I actually got him in that space to
admit that he was the worst FBI snitch
in history when you said that yeah
pretty pretty funny pretty right pretty
pretty spot on all of these people who
make this commentary and attack trans or
people or or attack other people for
their beliefs or whatever it is just
know that there's always some backstory
that says yep that's exactly who I
thought that person was well speaking of
knowing exactly who a person is oh you
guys don't know who this one or no and
space the time of the puppet show oh my
God speaking of of these [__] fashion
[__] these fascist
um not wanting trans people to even
touch guns I mean well listen the Second
Amendment is inalienable and it's
god-given to humans wink wink wink not
to that lgbtq people that's what that's
what they mean they they're dehumanizing
them is what I'm saying but here's
here's a booger sugar juice
yeah booger sugar Jr doing is a Hitler
thing let's listen to to Howell he shits
out Hitler here
folks it's literally happening it's
happening the media is framing that
Nashville Tennessee murder of three
innocent young children and three adults
at a Catholic school as
dangerous for the trans community
when when a Christian School was shot up
in Christian children killed in Cold
Blood by a trans murderer with a
Manifesto that says you mess with our
kids we'll kill your kids
their belief they're they're covering up
the nonsense remember folks there's a
clear epidemic of trans or non-binary
mass Shooters people who according to
the CDC make up 0.6 of the adult
population of this country you add in
children and it's significantly less
the media is totally silent except for
to blame
you or to call you a bigot for pointing
out the trend
what trend
how many transmitters have there been
let's let's look back one of one of the
people I'm trying to remember which uh
who was the one that identified as
non-binary
but is it non-binary so that they could
avoid a hate crime well there was two in
Colorado uh I actually have the graph
because if we remember like people are
gonna be like oh that's one that's one
of the arguments they're trying to say
oh this shooter identified as non-binary
as a legal cop-out just saying that
their attack on the lgbtq community was
not merited as a as a hate crime here
here we go so the Colorado Springs
shooter yeah that guy is not non-binary
right he is number non-binary the Denver
shooter now I'm I'm guessing this is in
the theater in Aurora is that right I'm
not sure if that's the person is that
the same one no I don't know let's see
Denver shooter identified as trans
um this shooter identify this range in
the Nashville shooter identify this
train so there's four there's four I
don't I don't know if uh
I don't know if Don Jr is aware of how
many mass shootings there actually are
right I think that's the confusion and
that's another thing that these [__]
idiots do in these spaces is they talk
about how oh well these aren't actually
Mass Shooters mass shootings it's it's
liberals it's liberals conflating
conflating uh shootings where more than
two people are a kid what the [__] are
you I I mean if we're we can Define mass
shooting right we can Define that and
then we can use that as the I don't know
the bar of what imagining is and then we
can say how many there are just because
you're uncomfortable with calling a mass
shooting what it is doesn't mean it's
not that thing just like you're
uncomfortable
identifying uh a man as a woman or a
woman as a man just because you're
uncomfortable with it that's a you
problem not not in everybody else
problem right so you're the one who are
scared of words you [__] right-wing
trolls one 100 and let's look at this
even if you were to count these four
people right and you say these four
shooters were trans okay there have been
300 over 300 Mass Shooters since 2009
okay uh and that would equate to 1.3 of
all Shooters now I know the other the
other stat I don't know the actual like
statistic here but there is a small
number because at first it was like oh
is it a woman that shot up this school
right it did a shooting at this at this
Covenant School which
on that alone you have to look at that
and say that's an that's that right
there is a rare instance of a shooting
because typically they are male or
they're white or they identify as
straight right
then you have women which is
significantly it is a rarity to see that
and then you have four Shooters who
let's say identify as transgender out of
over 300 Mass Shooters since 2009 it's
1.3 percent there is no Trend there is
no great majority right if we look at
the numbers which I know that Don Jr has
a hard time understanding maybe if I put
them in quotes or something just
the only thing he has hard time
understanding give me a book but at the
end of the day this whole fact of like
oh it's the trans community that is the
epidemic that language right there is
the harmful hurtful language the
dangerous language that the right is
using to attack the trans Community but
using under the guise of this recent
shooting and saying there's an upward
trend of trans Shooters and it's all
because of testosterone or it's because
uh you know we're changing their bodies
or this that's not what's going on
that's not what's going on and we also
have to understand that when you have
people like his best friend [__]
Benny Johnson trying to say the Colorado
Springs identified as non-binary Denver
was trans Aberdeen was trans Nashville
is trans it's very clear the modern
trans movement is radicalizing activists
into terrorists
um I'm gonna go on a on a limb here and
safely assume
that there is no trans movement however
the language they're using modern trans
movement is radicalizing activists into
terrorists that is what they're going to
try to use to push the idea that the
trans Community is dangerous and we
should limit any sort of uh gender
affirming care or treatment or anything
that would allow someone to say hey I
don't feel comfortable in this body and
I want it to transition even even as far
as confusing drag queens with
transgender people I mean that's how far
they're going here folks which is
ridiculous uh Joanna makes a statement
here and I'm not sure where you're
coming from but I I want I want to
address this
um and she says trans people are still
human it's a human thing and I don't
know if you mean the violence part or or
what what you're talking about there but
that's exactly what Don Jr what Ryan
what the right wing is trying to do in
this moment is to try to dehumanize them
they're using this tragic event in Nash
Nashville that's the cause of
dehumanizing not just drag queens who
they're confusing with trans people
because a trans person can be a drag
queen but but a drag queen is not a
trans person that's right and and that's
the thing too the the Republican party
conflates right you know oh they're
trans or they're drag or they're gay or
they're lesbian or whatever it is
they're just the intention yeah now the
one thing that I learned uh in this
space that I did not know and I went and
investigated did a little bit
investigating in it
um for a little bit I mean I'm like five
or ten minutes I did not know that the
majority the majority of trans people in
this country are especially that
identify as trans people in this country
are trans men meaning they are women who
have transitioned to men and that I
think is really [__] significant and
the reason why it's significant is
because the only thing they're focused
on is drag queens again they're
confusing and conflating a drag queen
with the Trans person which that that
it's not that's not the same
um and then they conflate the lgbtq
community in there because the t plus is
sometimes you know in there and it just
depends on who says what but here's the
thing is that
the reason why they're leveling the
argument in this space is because
they're trying to dehumanize these
people it is what Hitler did it is what
the Nazis did to Bolsheviks it is what
the Nazis did to Jewish people in
Germany and all around Europe it is
exactly what they did to gay people it
exactly what they did to trans people in
Europe yes they existed then it's kind
of funny trans people have been around
for a long time I don't know if you know
this or not but yet they've been around
for a long time but the one fact that I
found fascinating
um and I don't remember exactly who said
it and I think I disagree with the
person who said it and I was like well I
gotta go check that out
um because it made sense to me in my
mind that wow the reason why they're not
attacking trans men is because of the
misogyny of the attack on trans women
because that's where they want to level
the attack and the reason why is because
of the natural bias against
women that is exactly why they're using
trans women as the attack and the other
thing is they're uncomfortable if they
would to go to a bar talk to a very
beautiful women uh have a good
conversation be attracted to this woman
go home to sleep with this woman as if
any woman would sleep with them in the
first place yeah and then find out that
this person is trans that would terrify
the ever loving [__] out of them and not
because they would hate it because they
would like it that's the reason why yeah
um but uh Joanna their attempt is to
dehumanize them here and that is the
argument that's why I say that the
Second Amendment Bros the 2A Bros are
the plot line is slipping away from them
quickly and the reason why is because
they've made this argument of children
being murdered in schools now a
transgender argument so now not only do
they have to argue
their second amendment you cannot
infringe can't take it away it's
inalienable it is it is god-given and
then on the same hand make the opposite
argument for people who are who are
others right and that is where their
plot line is going to slip away and
that's why we have to keep pushing on
them and that's why I didn't get in the
space because I felt the push in that
space was going that direction they
weren't talking about mutilating
children's genitals in that space they
weren't and the reason why is because
that plot line is slipping through their
hands this shooter was not a 15 year old
trans person it was they were not they
were a 28 year old trans person who by
the way went to school and that church
and there is significant Evans at the
time that this person probably attended
that school in church that there was a
lot of sexual abuse in that school in
church by the way and we'll find that
out we'll see what comes of that and
also we know that there was a suicide
note not some manifest and I don't know
about the manifesto but I've seen the
suicide note that they left for their
friend on Instagram right and it was
suicide by cop right clearly if you read
the message but you know that's just me
and the the other thing I want to add to
that too is like
uh you know I was talking to some people
the other day or yesterday you know it
when the language of the manifesto right
I don't know what is in the manifesto
nobody does except the police and the
FBI who are investigating we'll probably
find out eventually we'll we'll find out
however you know if it really was a
Manifesto typically the the motive or
the reasoning behind it is like this
group of people I'm coming after like
the Buffalo Mass shooter right he
explicitly said in his Manifesto his
motive for going to kill 10 black people
okay he was very clear that was a hate
crime 100 there is no doubt about it
Josh Hawley obviously didn't speak up
one bit about that uh but now he is why
would he do that right exactly again it
doesn't fit his narrative right the same
way that he didn't vote for the hate
crimes bill in 2021 while there was a
rise in in anti-asian hate crimes right
now you see this party and they're
struggling you know like you said
they're losing the narrative it's
slipping away because what they're
finding is that what they once argued
is now being used against them in their
position on this trans shooter and now
they're like well well they came after
the Christian people they came after the
Christian students here's the question
kind of thing even though they have a
Manifesto
again in a Manifesto you'd probably have
explicit uh direction as to why someone
would do the thing that they did right
we haven't heard anything it's still
unknown even right now it's still a
known you you would imagine you know
even after the Buffalo uh shooting we we
learned I feel like within a day or so
that it was clear like oh this is why he
did it right we didn't see the manifesto
immediately but we heard from the police
what the in what the motive was right
now the place is like we don't know the
motive we don't know why what we do know
is that the student did go to that
school we do know that there are other
places and locations that they were
potentially going to Target now what
those places were still unknown the
police and investigators haven't told us
but we have to acknowledge the fact that
this this attack against the Christians
these these these young innocent
Christian kids and teachers
that narrative is going to fall apart
because if you look at it the police
even admitted while the location of the
school in the church were targets
possibly because of history at that at
that school in church
when the shooter went into the school
they indiscriminately shot people
they didn't say oh I'm coming after this
kid and I'm coming after this teacher
they indiscriminately shot up the school
right well and and the point is is
ultimately yes when the when the plot is
slipping away from their hands it is the
[__] guns like Loki says here and and
that is the difference and that's the
struggle that they're having with trying
to inject the transgender argument into
the Second Amendment argument that's why
it's slipping away from them because we
have never I mean
the left has never been like oh you you
the only time we're like take away your
guns is when it's a white dude like in
Buffalo who says I'm going to kill black
people like that like it doesn't matter
what shooting it is even this one I'm
saying it's the [__] guns
[__] I'm saying the same thing
the left the same same thing because we
know we know why those children those
three children as three teachers were
killed right in Nashville we know why
the reason why is because we allowed
this person to have access to weapons of
war that is why those people are dead
that's why it's the [__] guns and
that's why I say the plot is slipping
away from and that's why we got to get
loud because they're terrified even the
governor Tennessee Bill Lee that [__]
that drag queen piece of [__] I mean his
drag and he wants the bad drag shows by
the way that but he doesn't want us to
talk about banning guns we want to talk
about Ben drag shows but not banning
guns again it's because they know it's
slipping right and when it's slipping
that is usually when the left kind of
backs away we're like oh we got him now
haha showed you no that's when we should
[__] lean into it right and that's
the point is that it that it is the guns
and it's always the guns when you talk
about these shootings where children
being ripped apart in school or people
are being ripped apart in grocery stores
or churches or at a [__] parade
wherever it is whenever it is with a
[__] weapon of War when it's
happening it's the [__] gun but then
you have a piece of [__] like this um
representative Clyde this [__]
today look at this some [__] wearing
wearing his AR-15 look at there on his
uh on his tie as a tie tack what a
[__] scumbag listen when they're
telling you who they are [__] believe
them okay
[__] believe these people who they
are I mean Andrew Clyde is the same guy
who said that January 6 was just a
normal tourist visit right he's the guy
that literally was caught was on camera
trying to barricade a door with a desk
and and frantically like oh my God
against the wall okay but then after the
fact there's the revisionist
storytelling which is oh no January 6th
wasn't a bunch of domestic terrorists it
wasn't a bunch of riders there wasn't a
bunch of violence it was just a normal
tourist visit and and what you see with
with Andrew representative Andrew Clyde
is the same thing that he tried to do on
January 6th or after January 6th is he's
trying to make this whole situation not
about the guns the guns are good guns
you know Josh Hawley said guns the
semi-automatic rifles and assault
weapons they're used for sport he used
him for sport all the time they're not
used for killing people which is we are
considering the trend of how the AR-15
is used for literally almost every
single mass shooting as it is it is kind
of weird it's almost like it's the
[__] guns I mean it's it's almost
like if look again if we were to do some
magnomics here yeah if we figure out the
common denominator right is there
billions because uh Marjorie David or
green somewhere there's seven billion in
the equation right somewhere in there
but if we look at if
it would the underlying Factor right the
common denominator the thing at the
bottom of the line when you're you know
doing the math equation
it would seem to be that the connecting
dot the the recurring object in those
mass shootings the thing used to kill
people was a deadly assault weapon right
was it that's almost it's almost like
the gun manufacturers know this right
it's almost like hey we after the ban on
assault weapons and semi-automatic
rifles happened from 2000 from 1994 to
2004. it's almost like
gun manufacturers increased production
and pump those [__] out all
right and then you saw an increase in
mass shootings after 2004.
it's kind of crazy it's kind of crazy
especially when the numbers say the
decade before the ban and the decade
after the ban clearly indicate that
there was a is a greater number of of
shootings that happened and look the
1994 assault weapons ban wasn't perfect
there were loopholes and they had
problems if you want to look at a place
that actually did do a good job look at
the 1996 ban in Australia that one
actually fixed the problems at the 94
Bill had and if you look at that it was
a decrease in the homicide and a
decrease in suicide that are gun related
so again I know that Republicans have a
hard time with numbers but if we
literally look at the numbers the data
itself the raw data you can actually see
that tougher restrictions or bans on
assault weapons and semi-automatic
rifles because you don't [__] need
that to shoot a [__] deer
actually in decreases the homicide rate
and suicide rate
so the other thing that I want you as an
audience to do when these people are
pointing out well you can't give
transgender guns because they're not
humans and we can't we can't trust them
against I mean like we're saying yeah we
shouldn't trust everyone with guns like
that yeah yeah sure we shouldn't trust
everyone with gun just like willy-nilly
and I'm not talking about trans people
white people whatever I'm not talking
about your sexual orientation I'm just
saying you should be licensed registered
you should have [__] training well I
wonder if these guys it's not radical
right you do the same train when you get
your car they're okay with these people
having guns see this guy oh yeah well
actually actually it's not that they're
okay it's that when the topic of stuff
like this or the proud Boys in New York
and when you have people in the lgbtq
plus community stand up and either
defend themselves or uh you know berate
or like go after these Nazis you find
people on the right getting very
triggered by that and they said oh no
man no no no it's actually the drag
queens and it's the lgbtq plus Community
they're actually the real terrorists
they're terrorizing the Nazis it's like
you might want to pump the brakes on
that argument you're trying to make here
because it sounds like you're a Nazi
well we're going to point out every
single weekday every single one of them
Monday through Friday for two full hours
uh how these people and the plot is
slipping away from them and we're not
gonna let up on that at least so join us
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific right here on YouTube
make sure to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast it's free nine to nine
then cost you a thing to subscribe here
on the Johnny Michaels podcast also
follow us on Twitter while it's still
live at Tony Michaels pod download every
single episode on Apple's Spotify and
Google it's also free over there follow
us on Facebook if you're over there or
just have an account at D Tony Michaels
and then you know what subscribe to the
up wires YouTube channel as well the
upwire.com just go to the upright.com
you find the link there and if you got
an Amazon Prime account you can link
your Amazon Prime account to Twitch and
give us a couple dollars of a
Billionaire's money I'm not kidding just
link the two you get one free
subscription to Twitch with your Amazon
Prime account if you link the two and
give us that subscription we get a
couple bucks of Jeff bezos's money if
it's his money it's kind of Amazon's
money but you know kind of around about
Ray we're taking it out of that
asshole's pocket not a lot but a little
bit goes a long way sometimes
yeah so a little little hole in the
pocket I'm catching the change right
right also visit patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez to get all your extras for what
was that he's got several coming out
here soon I gotta I gotta what was that
on Josh Hawley talking about the
Nashville school school shooting that'll
be coming out later today I've got a
FaceTime call coming out I'll probably
have another FaceTime call with Don Jr a
lot of extra respect that yeah so a lot
of check it out go to patreon
patreon.com imgame Sanchez when you're
over there on patreon visit my page too
don't leave me out you sons of [__]
go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels uh
we're gonna do an ask me anything I
think on Friday tomorrow is gonna be a
rough day because I think I'm gonna get
wasted tonight probably so tomorrow will
be a rough day it might be tomorrow
might be Friday we'll don't ask me
anything and then we do the Sunday rants
I also have some new social media Clips
gonna be coming at you you get an early
look at those social media Clips so go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez if you
want to give us some monetary support
and get some extra content over there
and some Early Access to content and
behind the scenes that's where it's at
and where we'll be at tomorrow same time
same place even if I'm a little wasted
Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon